The reason I am doing this series, discussions, scene work,...
...one-on-one conversation about the craft of acting...
If you've done well in the business, it's your obligation to send the elevator back down.
Farther, farther, go farther, keep it up.
That kind of mentorship, when someone says something to you...
...at exactly the right moment that you need to hear it.
It feels like the only stakes are will you get emotional at the end.
Keep in that mode, sit on your hand.
Engage in the craft.
Put everything on cards.
Read a great classic play.
Go Netflix an extraordinary Spencer Tracy movie.
House of Cards.
House of Cards, whatever.
People aren't paying to see the top of your head.
Stand up like this.
I tell you it's right because it's a focus puller.
You gave me a great direction.
The craft of acting is to step into someone else's shoes,...
...someone else's ideas.
To look at something in a mirror and not see ourselves and not feel weird but feel free.
Hi, I'm Kevin Spacey and welcome to my master class.